Narrator: For years,
they've been called illegal.
Now the government says
they are essential.
That's the confusing reality
for at least half of the
2.4 million farmworkers
who plant and harvest our food
here in the United States.
Many produce pickers
are working under grueling conditions
with few safety measures in place.
And that was already a problem
even before hundreds began
testing positive for coronavirus
in farms across the country.
After 13 years working
in the fields of Southern California,
Carmelita still does not
have legal status in the US.
And because of that,
she cannot even think about signing up
for basic benefits,
like health insurance,
and she doesn't qualify
for a stimulus check
from the federal government.
Overcoming these kinds of challenges
isn't anything new for Carmelita.
What's different is
that now she's terrified of getting sick.
By mid-May, a vast
majority of farm laborers
around the country say
they had still not received
masks, gloves, or any
other protective equipment
from the companies they work for.
Carmelita had been taking
her own precautions.
But many of her coworkers
didn't believe or understand the outbreak,
so keeping social distance
has been difficult.
With peak harvesting
season already underway,
farmworker advocates fear
that negligence and lack of education
could lead to a major outbreak.
That, in turn,
could further disrupt
an already fragile supply chain
and leave empty shelves in grocery stores.
- We're treated as
essential workers right now
because if we don't do this kind of work,
the United States is not going to have
food in supermarkets,
food to feed the nation.
Narrator: One doctor from the same
county Carmelita lives in
has been trying to help.
Tipu Khan has been going from farm to farm
educating workers about the virus.
- They live in our community,
they function in our society.
So we want to get in to them
and really help them be safe.
Just trying to provide
basic medical education on how
to keep the infrastructure
of our society safe,
to keep the rest of society safe.
Narrator: Not all farms have welcomed him,
but he says some are taking steps
to protect their workers.
GoodFarms, which hires domestic workers
and international workers
with temporary work permits,
is putting hand-wash
stations in the fields.
- Part of the work that
we're having to do is
to not only look at the work,
but also interface with our teams in both
their personal lives
and the lives of their families.
Narrator: California leads the nation
in growing produce
and is home to 400,000 farmworkers,
of which an estimated
50% are unauthorized.
In mid-April, California
Governor Gavin Newsom
announced a one-time
COVID-19 relief payment
of $500 per adult to approximately
150,000 unauthorized immigrants.
He also said that farms
and other food industry businesses
must give workers an additional two weeks
of COVID-19 sick leave.
That would make a huge
difference for Carmelita,
who says her company normally only gives
three sick days per year.
More sick leave right now
would help with the current situation,
but this kind of work can be backbreaking
at the best of times, say advocates.
And the challenges for America's
undocumented farmworkers,
and ultimately its food supply, remain.
When Carmelita finishes her
12-hour shifts picking strawberries,
she heads to her two children
at a rented room in a mobile home.
She dreams of the security
that legal status would bring.
But the options for applying are limited,
and it can be very expensive.
The pandemic has only made it harder.
President Donald Trump
has used the outbreak
to suspend most legal immigration.
Temporary guest worker programs
have continued to protect the food supply.
But those programs only cover
10% of farmworkers in the US.
And it doesn't help Carmelita,
since she's been here without legal status
for more than a decade.
The "blue card" is part of a law
proposed by Democrats in 2017
that would give agricultural workers
the right to work,
and a path to permanent legal status
for them and their families.
Carmelita's sons were born in the US,
making them American citizens.
Still, she feels proud
of the work she does.